[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier six autres les biens mal et mieux
alors bienvenue dans des spas sorti de
l'auberge aujourd'hui ça nous les noix
monte dans les hauts de saint louis au
mac alors les mac c'est quoi les forêts
les sentiers les points de vue enfin
c'est un tas d'affaires et c'est aussi
pascal avec sa femme au visage avec son
exploitation agricole avec ses petits
animaux de basse-cour de sa présente à
nous tout ça dans une des meilleures
émissions de la télé normale je les
connais on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
non bon bah vous venez avec moi à l'aîné
[Musique]
bonjour pascal bannwarth à l'effort
saiss et demain on accourt on n'y arrive
pas à tous mais aussi d'accueil à nous
avec plaisir d'y aller ou s'annulent et
là nous les remarques nous l'assumons
exploitations agricoles aujourd'hui mais
il veut présenter ça parce que le vieil
alambic l'auberge de campagne c'est
d'abord une exploitation agricole
donc si nous les là aujourd'hui c'est
pour nous voir un petit peu ce que ce
que nous fait ce que
nous propose ou travail qu'ils
contiennent ne sais combien de mètres
carrés leurs nectars et comment alors
aujourd'hui l'exploitation il fait 9
hectares mais n'a à peu près deux
hectares et demi trois hectares
exploités mais là depuis trois mois on
connaît un peu compliqué mauvais ton etc
cyclone on a beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes donc ne se plie pas où comment
les dieux depuis trois marins mammifères
une petite dédicace à tout bon
agriculteur à tout bout de mon nez dans
le métier
les vrais que l'affluence moment n'est
pas facile beaucoup à elle n'est pas
facile du tout du tout mais nous tient
debout n'aura pas si un bel appartement
à la coupole couples ont en général
cette exploitation en général nous fait
fraises nous faisons du show nous fait
de l'ail nous fait un petit peu tout ce
qu'il dit et pis c'est un joyau vie à
tout bout du pied mais dans le cas du
créole d'accord donc un petit peu tout
ça tu peux tomates aussi temps en temps
donc vraiment nous un panel de culture
quand même assez large quand c'est
surtout pour pouvoir mettre ça sur la
table après et proposera bonne demande
pour manger et ils sont d'ailleurs ici à
taboye wilson larry direct chez à table
nous connaissent année sur l'autre nous
connectons en effet avec un économètre
dont et nous connaissons aussi avoir eu
affaire
[Musique]
alors là mais dans ce cas roads
artichauts alors qu'en même temps il
fait beau et que nous appelons tu es
d'accord c'est une plante c'est un
agriculteur qui qui pose quoi qu'on
problèmes au cou konan a quoi comme
comme avantage
le problème avec cette culture là c'est
surtout les incendies
je vois beaucoup aimé banza 5e bien
bonne pelouse du show donc sa série pose
un peu problème si ce plan n'est pas
bête
l'avantagé avec ça c'est que c'est une
plante novateur semiper père elle a
pleuré cela deux ans trois ans il va
continuer de stars du show il va donner
ses plans on voit bien replanter c'est
vrai qu'avant nous trouver ça c'est
notable des encours intéresse manger la
mise et a presque alors qu'aujourd'hui
on retrouve sur pas mal de table et vous
avez dit aussi qu'ils n'avaient à côté
les fraises c'est ça voilà à côté nous
narre les fraises bah pareil ça c' est
que dieu nous fait de groupes et de père
en fils dans ce café noix toujours à
fait et les fraises pareil avec ça nous
fait du jus nous fait des tartes aux
fraises nous fait des décès des salades
de fruits l'utilisent beaucoup aussi la
fraise aux caméras ou des diamants que
c'est c'est cette plantation depuis est
grand en pl est là et que dit loin et
fait presque mal à licques ont légué pas
de fraises ou moins que ne fait pas de
présent l'année parce que justement un
astre espi la bonne échappée voilà mon
mini chapeau numéro 10 a dit ogier à
lucciana de la force le boom alors nous
voilà arrivés à lanouaille alambic lever
l on vous disiez abraxas est depuis aux
parents tout cela ça voilà ça c'est
noble âge de comprendre que même à 31
ans jo du 31 ans je dis moi vous disiez
manquons face vous n'avez d'autre
d'autres légumes et d'autres trucs comme
et abouna songes ou même à groupies
monty python on a le teint ou dans les
rayons uv ou emma russie le gingembre et
où emma aussi le chouchou le bret de
chouchou et loulou et ça c'est un en
fait tout le monde les connaît
chouchou l'eau lorsque nous williams
proposées dont le chouchou par exemple
que le bret chouchou nous fêtons brenciu
nous fait fait casser debré touche on y
connaît
oui on utilise aussi le le pata pata que
je veux pas passer connaît encore plus
en plus rare et ça c'est une affaire qui
arrive la saison nous nous ferons un
plaisir de mettre à table et de faire
découvrir ou redécouvrir le patac
chouchou après notre idée aussi grand le
grain chaud chaud
notez bataille comme étaient petits
poumons dow jones où il m'était chouchou
et là ils disaient qu'ils étaient plus
sage qui a été plus sauvage qui était
plus méchant et guerra pas le grunge ou
en famille
[Musique]
vous montrez pas parce que nous on mange
et ben oui mais a eu le choix commandes
et comment alors le grain de chouchou
nippon le grain ni à chailland turmel
ensuite tenu fenty sauter avec sa dont
l'huile avec la
lot 2
en soi la freiner d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et moins pataud
quand il fait noir
alors pascal le vieil alambic
il faut bien tenant un alambic d'or quoi
quand même weaver voir l'alambic
alors pourquoi il appelle le vieil
alambic parce que cet alambic la lie
même les n'a déjà plus de 100 ans sont
les piliers la seule à passer de
génération en génération et un géranium
passera certainement pas trop vu moi
mais est on face voilà les chambres
d'hôtes les chambres est donc là ici
cette nana quatre chambres salle de
bains et toilettes privatives et là nous
peut accueillir nos voitures à peu près
une dizaine de personnes quel type de
moody s y est ce que vous n'en avoir
mais c'est parce que nous avons des
touristes on a des réunionnais ou nana
mais j'ai passé beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de nationalités vie à ben si
l'on reçoit tout type de monde reçoit
déjà bon touriste étranger qui se noie
allemand espagnol après bonn français
épinac révèle aussi nous causent pas
chinois nous causent pas anglais mais
contiendraient devant avec nous nous
pouvons battre sochaux
[Musique]
en plus mon coeur fait l'état cambonnais
sentie molle
[Musique]
on fait clair qu'elle a des sentiments
nous sommes encore là mais sa prépa
besoin d'un petit bourge boucané besoin
tout nappé djibo chouchou des pnj
brenciu de bois
un peu le lieu
michael
beaucoup mais nous voilà c'est bien
[Musique]
lavergne
m
[Musique]
stern hu est le bret matin
karakama
coq poids mari
[Musique]
déjà bon alors pas marmaille ne m'a rien
à dire ou appartement mais fini 48e
comment ou la lance à eau dans cette
activité
alors
déjà là bas c'était mes parts on l'a vu
ouvrir et ça il fait déjà 31 ans est
arrivé à un moment donné vas-y tu
commençais déjà un peu fatigués nous
revient après des années et des années
de travail que ce soit dans la terre ou
ici même à l'abandon de mon travail m'a
dit emma pas envie de l'acsa à la
retenue et c'est là comme la voile a
repris le flambeau le voilà le flambeau
créé un petit peu aux gens que les
enfants fassent la queue
quelles activités ou peut avoir tous
dommages pannes à des sentiers un des
points de vue ah oui alors ici aux
marques city vient déjà de tu peux aller
vers la fenêtre
un point de vue sur tout le siècle de
cilaos après avoir ouvert la fenêtre la
houlette de son entier dans tous les
coins on a dès son entrée par exemple
qui peut aller vers le cas nouvelle le
tapage que c'est des petits villages de
l'autre côté de la montagne là bas a
précisé marc même comme activité ou
neymar un centre équestre liban où elle
a aussi quelqu'un qui fait un petit
jardin de bonsaï que les super qu'il
vaut le coup d'aller visiter mais pense
que de trois jeux sur emma on ira pas
loin
nous étions n'y aura pas ce matin hama
point de soucis là dessus donc mais pas
pour tout le monde
vous avez vu comment les vagues at il
dit nous avons beau chalet à lévis
timide au début la regarde la caméra
leur grade azote comme ça c'est moi ça
voulait juste pour finir fait interoute
remerciements et ma mais voudrais
remercier les gens qui depuis le départ
depuis le début le vert en berne à 31
ans il continue de suivre non qui dit
aux régions départements de france jean
l'agriculture
tous les gens là et déjà participé de
près ou de loin à
au début et à la continuité de cette
cette activité parce que vraiment c'est
pour nous c'est très important c'est de
garder cette tradition comprenant une
robe à bahia à 96 garçons la tête à la
papa papa papa écoute mais laisse à vos
obligations parentales medio revoir mais
assez beaucoup de d'accueil
et puis je vais pas là-bas moi c'est bon
bon courage aux autres le bon salut
petit bonhomme au revoir petit bonhomme
[Musique]
l'émission se termine pour aujourd'hui
mais ne vous en faites pas que pour
aujourd'hui il ne va revenir
alors là on s'est arrêté dans le le ler
du pique nique des mac magnifiquement
grands pieds de cryptomérias les petits
chants des oiseaux
il fait bon y fait frais on à la forêt
de beaune accueille avec tous les arbres
endémiques mois miley jolie les jolies
la otra vs donati tibet lier la tire ou
ce gros on a toutes nos petits cardinal
tout partout voilà je pense qu'on a fait
un peu le tout cas
détail important de la vie très
important on n'est vraiment pas sorti de
l'auberge normal oui on n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge
emob ça tout de suite moins vite dans la
mal aimée ça fait notre invité l'arbre
les mac je t'aime
[Musique]